a recent study in the American Journal
of Epidemiology found people who do
strength based exercise have a 23% lower
risk of premature death it also reduced
their cancer mortality rate by 31% in a
new article in The New York Times
website how to build muscle in 9 minutes
dr. jordan Metzl says strength training
with weights is key for maintaining an
overall healthy body it is the latest
installment in his 9 minute workout
series dr. Metzl is a sports physician
at new york's Hospital for Special
Surgery welcome back good to see you
morning explain what you mean what can
we do in 9 minutes so 9 minutes people
often think you know it's New Year's I
want to be fit and active and I only
have a half hour or 20 minutes or 9
minutes in the message here is it
intense bouts of exercise in a short
period of time are really effective for
people to do so if they don't have time
to do a longer workout a short workout
for intensity with intensity is great so
how intense is this 9 minutes what
should you be doing so we try and get
people guys we've done 2 of these this
is the second about how to use
bodyweight and in this case light
weights to do workouts at home a series
of one-minute intern interval blast
makes a big difference when you talk
about light weights what do you mean so
basically people can use 3 pounds 5
pounds 10 pounds 15 pounds we generally
don't go about 15 or maybe 20 pounds
maximum but it's doing the high
repetition light weight training which
has almost equivalent strength gains to
bigger muscles how often do you need to
do this to really make it effective so
we want people the strength train you
know two or three times a week and then
do the other things they wanted we think
of strength training as kind of building
the muscle around the skeleton and that
allows you to do other things you'd like
to do so if you'd like to do golf or
walking or playing tennis this will
allow you to do those types of types of
exercises we have people you know 8 to
85 doing strength training so it's not
really it's not age dependent I had a
trainer who worked with someone else who
once told me you never see overweight
people in the weight room but you always
see overweight people on the treadmill
or the elliptical I've never forgotten
that point I've never forgotten that and
number 2 when you're talking about
weights I know a lot of women are
resistant because they think they're
gonna look like a dude or the Incredible
Hulk and to that you say what okay so
let me answer the second part first so
the idea of strength training is not
building muscle bulk it's building
kinetic chain strength tip to toe
strength now there's some sense that
kind of building strength increases your
metabolism that may be a little bit true
but not a lot bit true the biggest
difference
is intensity getting intensity up but
it's an interesting comment about people
losing weight I want people that to
Jordan I think he's right whenever I go
I now look so if you have a choice
between cardio or weights if you have a
choice what is your what do you
recommend so that kind of stuff we have
in the in the times today is a lot about
doing both so when you do things like
squats and jump squats and burpees and
using some of these weights for these
exercises well that's okay but the idea
is that your breast you know what they
are yeah no she's great but you're
building and you're doing intensity and
cardiovascular work with strength
training at the same time and it really
helps kind of symbolize what do you get
out of square strength training you
don't get out of cardio yeah
well it's a great question so with
cardio alone you don't build that
functional muscle strength around your
skeleton so if you have arthritic knees
or an achy back or whatever you know the
stronger you make your muscles the more
able you are to do everything else so we
want people to think about this and you
know people in their 20s and 30s think
about this people in their 70s and 80s
don't but we really want people to think
about doing this across their entire
lifespan it really helps yeah the
evidence is clear on this the data is
there about weight training and cardio
together thank you dr. Jordan met
soldier we appreciate it
for more on his how to build muscle in
nine minutes workout visit our website
CBS this morning dot-com Gail and I will
be lifting and exercising biscuiting
work on it right now I don't do that I
don't agree I agree with what you're
saying no we need to have a mental
workout